Coolio man oh yeah certainly oh hey I
gotta go
yeah Terry out there are you doing man
hey pretty good Gabe Oh
got something on your shirt not today
Terry
it's like Gabe's come out to play
you do have something on your shirt no I
don't yeah you kind of do that pretty
sure I don't got a clean shirt at my
dad's can fill me to get it for you
don't see why that would be necessary
because the shirts you have on right now
it's not clean except for that it is me
I have a clean shirt oh you you have
some schmutz on your Jameis Winston my
jammy-jam
you know what why don't I just get it
for you yeah why don't you do that there
we go I'm thinking damn you good mm-hmm
you know what the funny thing is what's
that now I guess from when I dabbed your
shirt with the paper towel and I'm not
playing the game right now but I
actually I must have got some paper
towel fuzz on your shirt so
hey how long is chairman wearing her
hair up like that
don't you have to go through that and
I'm sorry huh hey Terry what's going on
uh never a good morning I'm having a
terrific morning great hope there's
nothing on my shirt
because I can't look down oh no dude
we're not doing that right now okay
there's nothing on your shirt no one
cares about your shirt everything's not
about you try have a conversation with
Karen right now so
you okay Terry just pisses me off
oh yeah yeah I do have schmutz there
switz all over me now deny that Terry's
not gonna know what hit him
what what happened Terry died
hey Jerry
it's Gabe I am just wanted to let you
know that um that you didn't get me
Terry you didn't get me because on the
day that you died there was schmutz on
my shirt so guess who wins the game
Terry I do you lose
Oh